de vuelta a casa este domingo más de un
centenar de venezolanos regresaron a su
país lo hicieron desde arica en el norte
de Chile en un vuelo humanitario
costeado por el gobierno de Nicolás
maduro en el conocido como plan vuelta a
la patria
Sí igual desde el día uno que uno sale
los migrantes llevaban días varados en
la frontera entre chile y Perú primero
habían tratado de llegar a tacna en Perú
para seguir a pie hacia su destino final
de Estados Unidos pero fueron rechazados
por las autoridades migratorias peruanas
y terminaron en arica Chile hasta esta
resolución final afortunadamente las
reglas y las leyes de chile se pusieron
un poco fuerte para nosotros para
conseguir trabajo Fue un poco complicado
sin embargo bueno tuvimos que tomar la
decisión de regresar el presidente de
Chile Gabriel borics celebro el
desenlace
el primer vuelo
de venezolano
cabo soluciones el gobierno chavista por
su parte se auto anotó un tanto a su
política exterior en un nuevo Triunfo de
la diplomacia bolivariana de paz el
gobierno venezolano trajo de vuelta a Su
patria 115 con nacionales que se
encontraban varados en la frontera de
chile desde 2018 Cuando entró en vigor
este plan de regreso 30.000 personas
desde 25 naciones han vuelto a Venezuela